the historic west side received some
special care and cleanup today
this was part of the neighborhood
revitalization project with volunteers
from rebuilding together southern nevada
and republic services reporter kate
houston joins us live in the newsroom
tonight to share how this project
is really supporting the community kate
yes sasha more than 160 people spent
their sunday afternoon painting
and cleaning up the area this benefited
surrounding neighborhoods as well as the
andre agassi boys and girls club
the boys and girls club which became a
crucial access point for internet during
the pandemic
was due for a fresh coat of paint
volunteers spent hours making sure they
got every nook and cranny
meanwhile crews canvassed the
surrounding neighborhoods to paint the
curbing and pick up bulk trash
tree trimmers were also out in full
force offering services to the neighbors
for free
kenny carter has lived in this
neighborhood for 30 years and is happy
to see the beautification projects
he's noticed some positive changes in
the area you see new businesses coming
you know
a lot of new growth and it's good you
know
pretty soon i think you're going to see
a whole lot in the next year too
carter says this project is a great
benefit to the area especially for the
local kids
and his elderly neighbors he's noticed
more local organizations taking
interest in the historic west side and
hopes this will continue
this afternoon there were volunteers
from rebuilding together republic
services
and bolden area command as well as
others and this was all made possible by
a 65
thousand dollar grant back to you sasha